but when you're younger uh uh something
to think about as a woman is the type of
woman not the type of guy you want to
have sex with you the type of guy you
want to marry you is he going to be
attracted when you're showing all this
out or is he going to look at that and
think oh this is not what I want in a
wife because I think that a lot of women
they get confused they say oh when I do
this guys hit on me when I do this guys
sleep with me and then they then think
that that's the type of thing that will
get a guy to marry them but these are
two different things that you're
courting for have we created a problem
though as men
yes we have yes than